en gros quand bruno y est y anime
l'atelier initiation maloya il y à
prendre nous d'abord compté 2 le 2 une
fois on gagne comté ou nena le rythme ou
traput l'instrument que vous jouez
rouler bob piquer un triangle kayamb
vanille grégory ryan m l'a jamais joué
maloya poussé atteint 7,6 connaît pas le
nom les instruments zod les plutôt rap
slam r'n'b mais maloya les naissances
pouzols c'est une sorte d'héritage de la
réunion c'est le fait de pouvoir
transmettre des messages à travers une
musique qui vient d'ici et pas
d'ailleurs j'apprends de nouvelles
choses et donc ben voilà j'avais jamais
si a vendu combine tester des trucs que
j'aime bien en général
pour moi le maillot
c'est une emblématique de réunion e
j'aime bien écouter jégou de plus leur
âme mais j'écoute de temps en temps le
séga et le malgré mon père maloya puno
ils représentent la nation maloya
m'écoute de temps en temps quand mes
parents et que maloya de nos deux
nations un l'héritage un chantage si
nous mêmes artisans de la musique mais
nous nous partage pas ça avec les plus
jeunes
vous êtes le sens de la chose vous avez
quel âge auquel il participait manas est
d'accord oui toutes les musiques
extérieur et mon époux a payé moins
nourris plein jour de six mois mais si
zot i koné que ça c'est une pratique
zones zones différentes
le quai à bruno là commence bâton maloya
tardivement avec pat carey musique
à cause de l'histoire familiale soit
mentais un peu comme l'histoire maloya
interdit et réprimé les ordis reconnu
dans mon ancienne l'inscription au
patrimoine immatériel de l'unesco
draka quai de boisset la terre tient son
racing n'a pas y aller mieux ni moins
bien clottes
mais ce que les ans nous les ans nous
nous c'est ça si coupe à nous de quoi
nous les deux qui nous les noix bien
comme cause d'une longue ou a vu le tir
une veine folk ou la doudou l'hiver il
fait ainsi appel que bath se lon la
voilà collègues il fait plein de petits
à fait le cas
le limousin